hello and welcome to this video playing
JB g0 all of two is my squad okay and
something after try to improve upon k a
3 1 i'll show that ND this a 510 K but
now I can gain some space here for sure
now that we should before it's not
possible
jayat it doesn't look particularly
grateful black to be perfectly honest
it's weakening the light squares
enormously so how to do this but should
be three maybe then f3 or something like
that so hard to do this oh he exchanges
this voluntarily that's Wow okay if I go
knight c6 now he's taking night this
rook takes Bishop b2 hmm so beach was
hanging yeah i think i can add this
first 97 96 looks really bad oh sorry
sorry for all the wow this is like what
what is this doing am I not just winning
here Bishop g5 Queen h5 almost wins the
Queen it's very close yeah but I don't
understand it in many ways I can also
take c7 right
okay so just take on the aid or going
back looks far more logical but there's
not see form which is a little bit
awkward can also put this on b5 yeah but
I think I'd rather take this is this is
easier simpler to play no nights is six
his queen doesn't have many squares
where I cannot try pattern Bishop g5
queen age five after that it has zero
squares but i still cannot wrap it okay
I could have played Bishop g5 97 and I
know I'll do it I mean no I'll take it
it's too much material check it's a full
rook or tweaks changes on I mean a lot
so let's take the line look resigns I'll
take it strange game really yeah so I
actually think that this position is
close to unplayable you have those those
weaknesses with the bishop on b7 if
white is playing well you should win the
game now it's almost sense a winning
position strategically speaking at the
engine is on 1.5 which is probably a
fair is fair assessment yeah this is
helpful and would have wanted to trade
this bishop anyway to make the light
squares even more vulnerable and from
here yeah Bishop g5 there should be 71
did win the exchange but is also pretty
good yeah I could have done this now
Bishop g7 97 but okay check I did this
one move later pin and Windsor for work
yeah this whole this is opening here I
think it's actually quite interesting um
there are some weird points 1 point is
that black will play d 5 pin for example
after something like f3 first of all
is a potential um transposition into a
Queen's engine what like once even this
is a playable move and f3 I think they
have d5 and this is a funny funny kind
of position where we get to something
that is very much a green felt where f3
is played which is not strictly
necessary not sure about 83 to be honest
but after a five and a distance it's
perfectly justified he cannot go Bishop
before and for some reason he also
didn't want to play Bishop c5 which is
still making quite some sense in
connection with 85 yeah auntie as I said
I think this is strategically lost
almost okay well thanks for watching